よろしくお願いします
[音楽]
[笑い]
に
[音楽]
仕方が
さまに
[音楽]
加熱
[笑い]
したことがさまにする
[音楽]
間に
仕方がさまに
[音楽]
奏でる間に
近場の
様に
[音楽]
では次の目と
瞑想とします
私は
幸せでありませんように
私の
悩み苦しみがなくな
りますように
私の
願い事が
叶えられません
ように
私に
喋りの
光が
現れ
ますのに
私は
幸せでありますように
幸せであります
[音楽]
私は
幸せでありますよ
ね私は幸せでありますようにと繰り返し
念じます
昔の
人たち
が
幸せでありますよう
に私の
親しい
生命の
[音楽]
悩み苦しみが
なくなりますように
私の
少し
生命の
みんな
となかなえ
[音楽]
られますように
の
[音楽]
怒りが
現れませんよ
り私の
親しい
生命が
幸せであります
ように
[音楽]
[笑い]
幸せでありますよ
ね私の
知ら
せ
生命が
幸せであります
生命が幸せでありますように
繰り返し念じます
ものが
幸せであり
ますように
生きとしてるものの
悩み苦しみが
なくなりますように
生きとしてるものの
願い事が
叶え
られますように
引けるものにも
悟りの
光が
現れますように
生きて
いるものが
幸せでありますよ
[音楽]
ものが
幸せであります
ように
生きて
いるものが
幸せであります
ように
見て繰り返しに行きます
[音楽]
ものが
幸せでありますように
生きているもの
幸せにあります
[音楽]
はいありがとうございます
よろしくお願いします
今日の
飽和
説法の
会場のお布施は高橋
優子様でございます
高井さんのお父様が最近
亡くなられまして
お父様の
冥福を
宗教文字でこの
ホースの
なさいましたのでその
お父様
幸福でありますように
反論でありますように
解脱することができますようにと
誓願致します
また
よくさんの
ご希望で
全ての生命にも
移行したいとは思っていますですから全て
の生命も
幸福でありますこの孤独によって
幸福でありますようにします
では
今日の
説法に入ります
あのテーマはあの
公平と
平等とコーヒーという
2つの概念で
仏教的な
解説でございます
体力がないんだからね色々面白いことは
いっぱいあることあるんだけど
言うまでの元気かなんですまぁ
英語で言えばよく
アンジャストです日本
[音楽]
語でねまぁ
平等
教
公平
一緒ではないかとは思っているんですね
そういうのはこの俗世間で考えるほどの
単純なことじゃないんですで
仏教的にどんなタイプで取るべきかという
ことは
散々いるいろんな説法の中で
どちらちらとは言ってはいるんです
忘れているでしょうね
だから
実行してほしい
期待は関係なくなるんですね
でタイトルというのは
成り立たない平等というタイトに迫った
けどまず
二つに分けますねそこ
世間の考えと
仏教の考えはね
まぁ俗世間的にでも人間には個性があると
いうことは
一応いい加減ですか
認めてはいるんですまぁ
真剣に見てみてないんです
みんな自分の意見にみんなを
抑えて
潰して
まとめようとはしているんです
だからはっきりと言えば一人一人は独裁者
でなかなか力がないんですね
独裁的な気持ちを実行するために
それで腹が立って怒って
落ち込んでもう
平和を
壊して
ハチャメチャになってますけどね
でちょっと
普通知識的に生きてみればまあ
人間に
個性があるということはまぁ
当たり前だろうと
こんな当たり前だろうと言ったと人の個性
は認めないね
だから
続編
書いてあっても私にとって
面白くないんですね
一人一人が
互いに異なる
個人です
でそれと違って
勝手に作った
差別世界があります
そんなにも仏教もバカにするところまで
世間はすごく
利口で頭が進んでいるでしょう
この連中は古い話
ばっかり嫌がっちゃってとかね
そんな気持ち悪いとか信仰なんかは
まあよく散々言われますよ
という流ながら
詐欺の
信仰グループだったら
飛んで入るんです
政治家まで
だから
誰に文句言うのかとね
人間がこの
勝手に
自分の
個性を生かしてとことん
世界を差別するんですよで
勝手に実態私はこういうこと
国
によって差別する
民族
識別ね
肌の色だけで
動作です
それから
使う言語
地球上の人間はいろんな言葉喋ってますよ
それで
自分と違った言語を喋っているならばそれ
によってその人
差別しようとするんです
で文化
ものすごく人間というのはすごい
生命生き優れているんだから文化があるん
だとか何のことない文化を持って人差し
するんです
で
その
すごく
迷惑な宗教もそうで信仰もね
それも
自分と他を差別するために
使うんですねまた習慣も色々あり色々
面白いことは
人間には何でもいいんでしょう人
ばかりするためには人を
貶すためには
何でもいいんです
言いたいのは
あなたと私は違いますよと
私の方が
いくらか上だと
それ言いたいでしょう
だから何の本当にバカでしょう人に
個性があると言ったら終わりますよと
言いながらそういう気持ちでいるでしょう
事実事実として生命は平等同一ではないが
問題は
主観的な感情で
倒す差別すること
軽視すること
他人と戦うこと
他人に支配されることいろいろあります
支配することを支配されること
戦う
差別することを経営すること
もうあらゆること例えばこの怒り知っと
抱くことも
民主差別です
わかってないんだけど
まぁこれ即席のところだけ
説明しますからね
だから俗世間の
知識ではもう科学という肩こりありますね
でそこで
生命
は生命なんですね
で科学者さえ
生命の中で一番
トップにいるのは
ホーム整備やと
理由は分からない科学者
でそんなに得意になっているのかと
[拍手]
それであの
脳みそ使っているから
脳みそ使っていることが
言う
科学的に
優れているファッターであると
教えてほしいんです
生産するために
逆に人間もが一番
生き苦しいでしょうに
あらゆる
道具作らないと
人間も生きられないんだから
下手でしょうに
それは弱いという意味でしょうで
感謝するこの弱いという
データを
入れ替えちゃうんです
携帯が無くてもそこの時は元気で生きて
いるでしょうに
言葉のことあっても魚とは互いに
コミュニケーションしているでしょう
聞いた話になるとクジラとかはねかなり
長距離のいる
仲間とも
話したりしているみたい
はいまあ人間の世界そういう世界なんです
だからあの
科学という分野から見ても生命っていうの
は
DNAでできていてDNに誰だって同じ
ものなんです
しかし
組み立ては一人一人違う
同じ両親の子供2人歌っても
染色
同じじゃないんです
すごく違うんですでも
違うんだけど
同じDNAで
組み立ててはいるんですよ
まぁそういうことだから
まぁ
平等であり
個性があるということになるんだけど
それに基づいて生活はしないんですよ事件
ははい次に進んでみます
同じテーマ
成り立たない
平等世界これ仏教の説明
仏教は明らかにこの存在を見てみます
ですがどう一緒の個人に
ドイツの個人は
二人といないんです
私と似ている人がいるんだよといないん
です
仏教から見てもこれありえないんです
世間ではなんかあなたに似ている人は10
人ぐらい世の中でどこかにいるんだと話
あるでしょうねあれはもう
[音楽]
データに基づいた話ではないし
調べて達した気するんでもなくただ
自分がアホだから言っただけで言った最初
に言った人は
でアホな言葉だからただその
考えはずっと広がっちゃうんです
それって人間の面白い特色なんですよ考え
が間違っているならばいきなり人気が出て
くるんです
でみんなそれは考えに違うんです
事実事実というと
すごく嫌になっちゃって
出て行っちゃうというね
だから仏教から見ても
同一
同じ人間二人はいません
生命も同じ仏教は人間人間というよりも
賛美を去った
去ったという
生命生命という言葉使っているんです
だから科学者よりは仏教はこの
生命という言葉で
物事を語っているんです仏教の生命という
ところには人間も神々も入ります
残念ですけど
最近見たYouTubeでこの
神々というのはおかしいとこれは
宇宙
どこかどこかのあの
村山とかなんとかから
昔聞いて
人間が無理やり作っちゃって
遺伝子組み立てて
でまた
後で開発してから
聞きますよと言って出て行っちゃったと
いうことでねそれはまぁ地球上のどんな
文化も
神が再びくるんだよとこの神という単語で
現れていたんだと
すごく
証拠になっているのは
古い文化なんですね
どうやってもどう考えてもああいうものは
作れないんだと
人間の能力では
だから
失うかこのカットして組み立てるこの
イント
切って
繋げると
石はもう
60キロ
50キロ遠いところにあるものでないと
どうやって運んだのかとかねそこで
家電技術のためには
精密に計算が必要なんです
当時で人間がそんな計算できれなかったと
今も難しいやとレーサー技術はあっても
あれほど整列にやんな方しようねまた大き
さ
それはできませんよと
そこでこの
グループアラン掘ったところ見てみんな
びっくりしたんですよこの
振ったものを釘みたいなものを取り出して
その
未だにどんな優れた大問のカッター使って
もあれほど精密には
過信できませんよ
ということでいろいろわからないこと
いっぱいありませんいろんな文化がねまぁ
ありましてそれぞれ
文化は
突然何で消えたのかというねなんで
すごい開発していて
どういうことでまぁ
地球外の
生命かけて
でまた
一角食べるんだよと
まぁ
勝手に来てくださいその私はいないんだ
から関係なんです
で
しかし仏教の場合は
神々
じゃあ
仏教でやりますからね
地球外の生命とかね
それ全てまとめて
生命として見て
平等はないやと言ってる人に違うんだよと
本来の心は同じですが
信者と働くので
個性が現れます仏教の考えはなぜ生命かと
いうとこの物体の中に
心が働いているんですね
フィーリングという機能
感じる機能が入っているんですね
それは
物質ではないんです
電磁波でも何度もないんです
このフィリンキのが
物質をいじったりする
だから
今は世にある
技術で
この感じることは
科学物質で説明しようとする
まだまだ原始レベルなんです
だから感じたから
物質を変化させるんです
それは感じる
能力のしかできないんです
だから
物質の
出来ているあの
あれを
変えるということは
で
我々今このいろんなもの
合成したり
焼いたりいろんなこと
合わせたりする技術持ってますけどそれも
結局心がやっているんです
しかし身体の中では
ずっと物質変化
受けて
いるんでだからそれだけ見てね
まぁこういうこういうホルモンでいるんだ
とかね
で
怪我したらまぁそこで
電気信号で脳に
伝えたら
脳が痛みを
作るんだとかね
痛み作る物質はこういうものだとかねあれ
はこれやと言ってますけどね
でも基本的には
感じるというところからして感じることで
いきなり身体の中で
瞬時に物質変化を起こるんです
だからそれは人間であれば神々であろうか
同じことや
だったらみんな
同じと言っても
心
感じることは
心は同じですよ
心はこの信条という
組み合わせる仲間が
タッターがあるんですね
それによって
結構
違う働きはするんですそれで
個性っていうものは成り立つんです
それで
仏教は全て科学的に計算してみますから
心は一つのファクターで
信条っていうのは502
種類しかないんです
だから52が
またグループに分けて
一緒に活動で可能なグループ
決して一緒には活動しないくる
それぞれ分けて
で必ず必要な
心情
まぁどちらでも入ってその色に染める心情
とかね
まぁそういう風に分けているわけで
それぞれの心
別々に名前付けて
であるんですよ
そういうところで私たち仏教の人々私は
個人的にもうちょっといろいろ
物足らないところもあってちょっとこの
データが
余計でいらないでしょうとか個人的にある
一般人に至って意味がないんですだから
まぁ
自分だけ知っておいて
いくつかの心象を足らないんじゃないかな
とかね
しかしそういう考えは
まぁ世間の人間には不可能でできません
とにかくそれも
すごい危険なことだからまぁ一応
必要なものだけ解きますという
態度だからね
要らんこと言いませんよと
世界不安のことは言えませんよと言って
人間に力士理解できてなおかつ必要
そのセクションだけ覚えておくと
いうことで
仏教心理学で生きているんです
そこでこの心の働きを説明するところで
他を差別軽視することで
自分の
心がさらに
汚れて
低次元のレベルに行くんです
で最近の人間がこの宇宙の話に興味ある
そうでは皆様どうかわからんだけどねまぁ
興味なかったら寝てくださいこの間で
だから神々なんか仏教のインチキな話やと
いうならば
考えてくださいよとでも人間が
素粒子世界知らないでしょうに
人間には
全く
NGにアクセスできないでしょうに
人間が学校と
勝手に名付けている
全く
ブラックでない
あの天体
もったいないと違った
膨大なエネルギー持って働いてますよ
そこからいろんな
物質物体天体出すんです
シュッするんですね
ですからこのそういうこともわからなくて
ねだからまぁ
いいんだけどまぁ
神々で
認めませんと言ったら
構いませんそれで
この
心と心情のあり様によって
今我々の心が三次元の世界で
我々知っているほんの僅かな物質の中に
閉じ込まれているんですね
我々の心にはそれ以上認識できない
電磁波とか波長認識できない
それはアウト
モニターで
普通の光のあれ出してくれない限りは何が
起こるかわからないんです何が起きたって
も
我々はモニターが今の光でちょっとした
変化でしょうまぁそれで
頭の中で画像をイメージ作っているんです
本当はこの意識に画像何も映ってないん
です
ですから人間っていうのはものすごい制限
された小さな世界にいるんですねそれは
心の能力範囲なんです
心にはそれしかできない
それで
この
楽しみを差別したり
ケースしたりすることで
自分の心がさらに
汚れて
弱くなるんです
できたことはできなくなるんです
そうすると
低次元
で
活動するんです
まぁ仏教ではこれ地獄次元が地獄次元で
ものすごくやるんですよ
ヨーロッパの宗教で行ったりような
プレイした天国人間地獄そんなもんじゃ
ないんです
後であの人々は色々妄想してね地獄の
レベルやら天国のレベルなら考えたんで
こんなおかしいやと
プレイステップの説明は
まぁスイランから誰かのこの一般人の人気
を
獲得するための説法する誰か坊主に聞か
なくちゃか
計算するとどれくらい地獄があるのか計算
できますけどものすごい重なります
すごくたくさんあるんです
面白くないんだから私は計算していないね
まず巨大な地獄4つの次元があって
8かわからん
8やります
その周りに
何か重力重力16ぐらいまた
別な次元のこの
肩こり
宇宙と同じ話です
肩こりがあってそのその周りになる地獄に
またまた
達した地獄がありまして
それは私はこんな
嘘やって勉強しなかったんだ若い時は彼女
頑固でしたからね
でもあれもちょっとラッピングするすれば
良かったなと思うんですよ
今もうあまり興味がないんですからね
一応テキストには
経典というよりテキストには書いてあるん
ですマッピーだからこの
なんか今宇宙のこと知っているでしょうね
だから我々の
太陽よりはもう1000倍
力のある
温度のある
太陽たちがあったりとかねだから青色で
人間の機会にする対応を立ち会ったり
それぞれキャスターあるんでしょうね
だからそれはこのGalaxyというん
ですけどね
だからGalaxyはGalaxyでお
互い
くっついたり
食われてしまったり
我々いるから私も今どこかにぶつかって
いるんでしょうしね
だからそれでこの
地獄という
Galaxyクラスターたちがあり得る
で
そちらも
心がないと生命じゃないんですね
私たちはこのカーボンでできているんだ
からカバンでね
我々にはこれぐらいの温度で
この
複雑なものを作ったんだからそれを何とか
守るためにこうね酸素が一周し環境が必要
しその
本当に条件少な
い宇宙でねものすごい
条件少ないなかなか稀な条件でこのこう
いうDNAで出来ている
まぁ
生命がいるんだけどねまた理由の生命は
他の
いくらでもいられるでしょうししかし
条件が
我々と違った条件
もっとすごい熱くても大丈夫とかね
極寒な
ところでも大丈夫やとかね
あり得ることはあり得るんです人間には
知る余地もないだけだからお釈迦様は
考えるなよと
場合は何も結論に得られませんよとそれで
心強く
だからこの仏教ではこの人を差別したりし
たり
若輩は作れているあなた方は何や何者やと
いう
態度で自分の心が
汚れちゃうんですねということは
次元が
下がるんですでこの世の中でこの100人
足らない
本当にわずかな瞬間しか生きてないよ
宇宙の
ねぇ時間っていうのは膨大だから
ですからもう
我々は信じられなくない瞬間でしかね人類
というものは生きていないし
ですからその短い人生でも
自分が人を差別したり軽視したりいろんな
嫉妬したり憎しんだり
全て
差別なんです
生命差別しないと思ったら
怒らないよ
嫉妬も出てこない恨みも出てこない
憎しみも出てこない
意欲も出てこないん
ですだから欲が生じたということはあなた
は差別意識を
作ったということで男は女の子と好きに
なるでしょう
女で見えたっても物質が変わった同じ生命
やと
思ったら欲を生まれないでしょう
そういうわけで
仏教を面白いこと
生命は平等じゃありません
これは科学的に言うんです
個性があるんだよ
だからといってあなた
タオを
差別したり軽蔑しちゃうとあなたが
ダラダラダラダラダラと
落ちるんだよと
せっかく心
と物質のこれ
セットいただいたのは
この物質を使用して
心向上させるためなんです
それやりなさい
ですからこの
悪行為ですね
受け止めませんよだからみんなやっている
んです
で
そういうわけで違いがあっても差別はダメ
ですということは
仏教の立場なんですはい
それでまた
仏教の話になります
5何でかく生命が
ユニットで別ですかと
おそらく日本
酒をレベル3で
何革命あれば
[音楽]
産業革命
あれで我々は
ファットに向上作っちゃって
品物を作るんですね
そうすると全部みんな同じでしょう
そこで頭いかれちゃって人間平等といった
可能性あります
そこで
書いてなかっただけ書いてあったかどうか
はどこかに書いたような気がしますけどね
生物学者にはこの
クラウンすることはできますねそれすごい
審判だと
でも最近読んだ文章でね
あんなのも少し
単純が
でも
モラリティに反するからあの
法律で気にされているのならやってないん
だよと
エジプト時代ではやっていたんだと
エクササイルスたちが
だから港はあるとかねあの
体が
馬で
頭だけ人間でとかねなんか色々そういう骨
とかね
見つかったという話もあるしね
で私のポイントは
これは
証拠ないんですけど
仏教的な理論で推測します人間が
作っても
このクローン生命が
命として生きているならば
個性あるんです
これはどうしようもないんです
心が張り込む張り込まないと
命にならないんです
だからクローンする場合は
簡単簡単と言ってもやっぱりあの
細胞2つ一緒でしょうしね
結局女性の乱視を使わなくちゃいけないし
ね人間作る場合は
卵子の過去を捨てて
別な格好を入れちゃえば
乱視細胞が
増えますからね
それでどうなるかわからない本当は
だからそれすごいやばい
な研究になるんです一応
研究してないんだけど
コピーという言葉使うんですね
しかし
ブッダの話によりますと
心が張り込むので生命にならないんです
心は膨大宇宙より膨大なエネルギーだから
心は一個一個別ですけどいくらなあかんで
も
至って簡単に入ります
でも私はそれでも個性がありとはあるとは
なんか自分の主観で言いたいんです
それただの主観です
はい次に語の話に入り
入ってみましょう
[音楽]
GOっていうのは
書いてなかったと
生命
生かせる
生命として
ライフファンクショニング生命活動させる
エネルギーのことなんです
これ
心の世界だから
物質
物理学者にはそれは
発見することも研究することも不可能です
例えば説教だったら何かエネルギーがある
んですけど
別のエネルギーに変えられますね簡単に
これ燃やして
燃やすと出てくる
[音楽]
を別なものに入れ替えることはできます
そこで
心も活動したいんだけど
活動するためには
燃料が必要です
それは心にあるんです
心は物ではないんだから
別に
イメージで
考えないでください
でっかい証拠を持っているのかどうかね
もう時空関係心にないんです
まぁ
分かりますけど
でも
空間アイスペースという次元がないんです
だから
膨大な
経ってもでっかい心になるわけじゃないん
です
イスペースないんだからね
で心には膨大なエネルギーが
溜まっているんです
それで心が活動するたびにエネルギーを
またあの
実験に
入れて入れて
怖いんです
だから
仏教を読んでは
生命は
生命はね
神々も地獄すべて
どんな生命もどこまで
ハチャメチャ生きてみたってもう
生命エネルギーは
消える増えることは消えません
なぜかというとこの
すごい面白いシステムなんですよ
[音楽]
最近色々言うでしょう何エネルギーでし
たっけ
再生
可能なエネルギーとかね
色は新しい単語できているでしょう
例えば
太陽で電気作ろうと言ったら
全然大丈夫ですねまぁいくらでもまぁ再生
できる
で心は逆に
まぁ働きですよ
例えば心ということは太陽神的に比較し
ましょうか
[音楽]
太陽に当たって電気が溜まったらその電気
使うでしょうあの電気使うと
充電もするんです
それで
無限という言葉わかるでしょう皆様の懐中
電灯
例に出しましょうか
懐中電灯にはこの電池入れて
おいてしかしこの
懐中電灯を
使うたびに
電池が充電するならば
どうしますか
冗談やめたければ
懐中電灯のスイッチ押さないで
暗いままで置いておかなくちゃいけない
それでも電池があるんだからまた
充電
始まるんですですからこの会場伝統で
考えれば
皆様知っている
現代知識の
数学で考えてください
懐中電灯しちゃうと
光っちゃうで
それで電池が充電になるそうするとあの
懐中電灯は
ずーっと手掛けるでしょう
だって
光を出すために充電するんだから
すると無限に怒るはずなんです
そこで
LED電池が
ledライトが壊れだしましょう
別のものさせばいいでしょう
そうすると懐中電灯が再生しちゃってまた
光っている
このこれは物質世界ではありえない話
心の世界であります
あり得るではなくてある話す
心を動かすためには
GOとエネルギーが一緒燃料それにGOと
いうんですしかし
業の場合は
使っちゃったら
歩けなくたくさん
蓄積するんです
だからこれお釈迦様この
ポイントも
俗世間の人間には
世界不可能なポイントを一つやと
だから私はちょっとしてぶつける物理学に
合わせて説明したでしょうに
そうすると何か変ありえないという感じに
なるでしょうに
物質世界ではそんなことあり得ないんです
それでこの心が回転する
業の場合はこの
自分持っている
燃料でしょう
この
燃料の場合は
貸し借り不可能です
心の燃料は
貸し借り不可能だから
自分で
作るんです
この法則
わからないんだからお釈迦様は出家にこれ
に
念じてください
罪に思い出してみてくださいたくさん項目
ありますけどこの
業のラインだけこれワンラインでしょう
文化して書いちゃったんだけどね
我々念じるプレスたくさんあります
その中でワンラインこれは
本当に
自分のセクションの中に入っていてまた
二酸化症にもありますけど
この10個もこの一つは5項目なんです
で
説明するためにこの
6ラインに分けたんだけど
普通はバンラインなんだ
巻末とこの
場合はどうか
も
それだけです
バンバインです
で
順番に入れたんだから順番として説明して
いきます1自分とは
自分の
物と言えるのは5です
エネルギーです
本当は自分のもの何もないと仏教で言って
ますよこれは肉体中心に勝ったらあなたの
ものは何もないん
しかし業
が
自分のもの
と言えます
人生命のアイデンティティは
業になっているんです
だから学生命が自分の業を持っています
から
生命のアイデンティティ
私は
個人ですと
自分の個性
業にあるんです合格
現在
生命が行う氷のポテンシャルは5ですね
だから過去で行った行為のエネルギー今
現在を行っている行為のエネルギーは
ポジションになっちゃって
GOというんです
そのエネルギーを他人に任せて逃げること
は不可能です
これちょっとあなた
持ってくださいと
自分に気楽になることはできません
これだけは
お金みたいにあげたりもらったり不感です
合流って自分の存在が構成されているのだ
と理解することも
正気にするこれ理解する人はお釈迦様は
証券
シャンマー
と言っているんです
この
ワンレースの
最初の
ワード
感増してこうにというだけ
それ理解できればあなたに証券があるんだ
よとそれは
専門用語で巻末せ方3枚出ているんですだ
からたった
人単語で
人間に理解不可能な膨大なこのエネルギー
世界を
生命に世界を与えているんです
これ英訳すると
オフカンマンアイアンシチュート
私は作られているんだよとちょっと
英語を読む人々の気持ちに合わせてそう
いう
訳しているんです
日本語で
自分で言えるのはゴーヤと5だと理解すれ
ばこの
難しい英語単語は結構です
2番目相続モールするもの
まぁ相続するということはこのエネルギー
は
命変わっても変わっても懐中電灯の
電池
変わっても変わっても
電池同じです
間違った
懐中電灯のあれ
ライトを変えても変えても
電柱同じです
だから新しい
ライト入れちゃうとあのライトがこのこれ
装飾するんです
自分は
業を増殖して生まれるのです
ですから今人間というライトになっちゃっ
たんだからね
語は相続しているんです
まぁ失礼で言えば我々は
犬という
ledライトになっちゃうとなっても
同じ語を創作しているんです
自分の人生がどのように流れるのかと業に
よって定められます
あれ自己管理不可能なところもありますよ
命の場合で
生命は
相違でしたこれはい
異なる能力を持って
生まれるんです
生命っていうのは
みんな
互い違いますよ
それは
何ですね
銅装束しているこれやあれ変換交換でき
ませんだからね
他人のことを
羨ましく思っても恨んでも惨めになっても
意味なりません
だからこれ理解してくださいとあの人は何
で能力ですかとかね
人は寒さも
歌える人もいて歌えない人もいる
耳でどんな音でも区別できるすっごい能力
聴覚能力ある人もいて
ほとんど鈍感で
人がいる
はいだからまぁあれうれしい
自分がみじみ人の能力見て恨んだりとかね
業の話知らない人がねそんなことやって
酷い目に遭うんですだってそれによって
自分の心が
汚れて定義になるでしょう
だからブッダの心理知らないことって本当
に可哀想なんです
みんな頑張って自分の心を定次元に定義現
にしているんです
自分と他人を比べることも無駄なく多い
です
GOを装飾してもそれを開発することより
良いものに変えることなどは可能です
これ
装飾という単語だから使ったんです
生まれる生命が
生きるために必要なエネルギーはいっぱい
持って生まれるんですでもなんか
使い方あまりなんか使えないとお金例えば
目はない
生まれたんだけどね
[音楽]
の
問題なんです
じゃあ人間の生まれたんだけど根がないん
だと
じゃあ落ち込んで悲観的になって
宇宙
憎しみで
神も人間も恨んだりして
ハチャメチャになる
それ意味じゃないんです
だから
法則っていうのは俗世間に入れ替え
ましょうか
ある人は親から
親が亡くなって
親の
財産100万
相続する
歩いては親の財産で
まぁ5000万を相続する
これは数字見たら5000万の方が
羨ましいね
でも理性あるお父さんからお父さんが
100万人だからこれ
物の肉体に使ってみますよ
言って億万長者になれますよ
頑張れば
1000万いいこんな体験どうやって使う
のかと思って
遊んで遊んで一年で2年で
借金になる可能性もあります
だから
GOっていうのは
相続するんだと言ったことは
業の管理
やってくださいなんですそれは
仏教以外誰も教えてくれませんよ
装飾した業の
管理の仕方
仏教で教えてありますこれ英訳すると感銘
しないんですねはい次に行きます3番目
自分の生みの親誰ですかね
カンマように
それも業なんです
自分の産業や
自分のこうなんです
生命の
母という意味です
人間に限らず生命は
多数
多主より
多次元です
犬の生命いるでしょうに
業がそのように生命を
作り出すんです
ね耳すぎるしゴキブリもいるし
毛虫もいるしね
いろんな形の生命を
動かす作るんです
だから海の親は
業です
それも自分と他の違いを
理性的に観察するために必要です
私と楽しい生命は
同一ではない
個性があるんだよと
理性で理解するんですその場合はその人は
その
生命はその
生命に業によって
生まれているんだよと
創造者がいるとすると
例えば
全て作った何か
奴がいると思っちゃうと
何か論理崩れますよ
なんでなんで俺は
障害者として
作ったんですか
何で俺は
耳が聞こえない
何とかっていうね
人間として
作ったのかと
何で私の
遺伝子に問題があって発見するように
かかっているのかと
何で私はどん底貧困ですけど
他の人々は
すごい豊かですかと
神は何やっているのかとこれ
成り立たないこの
世界は
一つの工場で作ったならば
神という工場で
トラック
そうやって言っているでしょう
ヨーロッパ人には
神々
あいつは変な工場を持ってますね結局は
だからこの
世の中の一個一個違うということを説明
するためにあれ
物足らないんです
そうすると裏も気持ちにもなります
仏教はそれじゃなくて
合法があなたを産んだよと
それで
GOってね自分というものでしょう
裏も相手が無くなっちゃうでしょう
業がこのカラス作ったんですかこの
ゴーヤル
自分のものだからね
だからタオルのことは仏教
理性で知って知っているならばなりたく
ないんです
海の親が自分の
過去の業になると
他人を恨んだり
両親に文句を
言ったりする必要はなくなります
バカがいるよ何でお子さん
お父さんお母さんお母さん私を産んだのか
いと
日本のお母さんでいる答えられなくて
言っちゃえば
お前勝手に生まれたんだよ
迷惑
目で勝手に妊娠するでしょう
そのお母さんが落ち込んで私にも聞く一緒
に
うちの娘にどう言えばいいんでしょうかね
とかね
何も唯一じゃないんです
だから仏教を受けだったらそれ楽チン
でしょうお前の具合と
こちら巻きで迷惑やと
ガタガタガタガタまとめのない業で
業を持ってきて
という風に言えるでしょうに
人を恨むなよと
自分の子を自分で整理し整頓しなさい
管理しなさいよと
この
ポイントでいくら努力しても変化不可能な
ところもある
と理解できます
心配じゃないんです人は頑張れば幸せに
なりますよ
でもどこかで頑張っても頑張っても
成り立たないものもある
これこの役はすごくかっこいいんです
あんまりしてメトリックス
している方々理解してください今説明でき
んこれ科学的に
言葉です最終的に行きます
それから真の親戚
から人間社会見てこの言葉使っているん
ですね
我々この世で生まれたらどうしようもない
親戚がついてくるでしょう
どうしようもないんですね
どんな人間にもねおじさんがいるおばさん
がいるわ
色々
親戚はいる
特に血縁の成績はね
どうにもならね
馬鹿者が親と生まれた途端結いているん
ですか
英訳ではね
親戚は
業であると
生まれる人に
血縁の親戚がいます
嫌だと思ってもどうにもならないでしょう
生命の血縁の
親戚とはこうです
そうすると
決戦式で人間だけでしょう
耳すりもありますからね
耳掃除さんの女に行かないしね
でおばあちゃんのちょっと面倒見よう様子
見はないでしょう
でも
本当に全ての生命に
親戚がいるんですそれを自分のゴールなん
です
で助けてもらうことも
邪魔されることもありますね親戚の場合は
いい親戚に恵まれて良かったという可能性
もあるし
あのなんかのおじさんが一緒で金くれ金
くれて金あげても酒飲んで掛け声で
パチンコでいくら
意味がないんだから迷惑も迷惑だと思って
も
決戦の親戚だからどうしようもない
でしょう
探してくる
だから
生命として
自分
時々助けてくれたり時々人生ダメになっ
たり
全部は
何て言いますか
ダウンフォールになったりあるいは
好転したりあるでしょう波があれ
具がやっているんです
これ
ここで自分の
業を
うまく活用することができれば良い
でしょうだから業の管理をして
ダウンフォール
落ちるとなったらさっさと考えて考えて
どうやってこれから抜けるのかとかね
考えた方がいいじゃないかなと思います
最終的に行きます
そこで頼りになるもの
助けても
助けていようと
言いたければそれも業なんです
助けること
これ助けるよりもまあ
業を支えられて強に支えられて生きている
んですねカンマパキサーの
自分の業を理性的に管理するならばその時
頼りになるのも自分の業です
業を
否定したからとこれ言っては間違ってます
ね
業を否定したからといって
問題は解決しませんね現代人が
傲慢で5を否定するでしょうどうぞあなた
の問題解決したのかと
これから
幸福になりたいと思う場合も5を管理する
ことになります
だから俗世間でいう話と違って
自分が
幸福になりたいと思うならば自分の
業を管理することでしょう
ぴったしの答え
自己啓発とか何とかとかね
自己警告書からいっぱい本あるでしょう
あれよりはぴったしの論理的な
答えは
自分の交換で示す
管理してくださいと
はい最後の
項目ですねこうに対して
今の子
ね
気づける気づける
それは
戒め文章で
6番目のラインはね
今行う行為は
善であれ悪であれそれを装飾することに
なるのです
人の生き方がその人は相続するので今の
行為に
気づけるべきです
楽ちんじゃないんです
不活に何かやったから出て結果が来ます
だって相続しなくちゃあんだから
感情に流されて生きることは
正しくないと言います
普通人間というのは怒りやらよくやら嫉妬
やらね
色んな感情で生きているでしょう
危ないんです
全部ポテンシャルたまるんです
それでここはあまり時空関係考えてないん
だから
どんな時結果ですかわからない
まぁ時間的なこの物質的な宇宙とか
あると時間成り立つだけで
別にも時間という次元がありますが
いつかということはもう
無限に
やったことの結果はいつか出るんです
将来を計画
立てる人も
考えるべきポイントですこのように
強盗エネルギーによって
各生命に個性があるのです
ですから人間平等だとという
相談は
歌うだけでは
意味がありません
こんな愚かなものおらかものを歌っている
だけで歌っているのは実行しなさいよと
こちら言いたいんだけどね
仏教すごい行動のレベルでなぜ生命が人間
ではないんです私生命が
個性があって
互い違いますかこれ業がやっているんです
棒だけ自分のものなんです
だから自分に業を管理できる
生命差別することは
自分の業を
悪剛にすることで
心汚れることで
次元が
落ちるんです
はい
もうちょっと平等な意味これは他人に対し
て
育てる気持ちですですから仏教の説法をし
ます
平等っていうのはこんな歌っても意味が
ないんです
我々は
本当に
自己中心に生きて生きようとしているん
です
それは
業の仕業なんです
だから自己中心ではなくと
自分が
個人である
この功を作ったのは
語である
理解しなくちゃあかん
ですから
全ての生命は業によって生まれている人々
導入って左右されていて
だから私は冷静に見ますと
あの人は出にくいとこの人は美しいとか
思ったらあかん
思っちゃいますね
だからそこで感情作れたら美しい人と
自分が欲の感情を作って
自分の次元を下げる
すごい美しいなぁとかね
100万人に1人もそんな美しい人間が
現れないまぁなるほどこの方の
業がそこから救っているんだよと
見にくい歌ってその
方の業がそういう体
作っているんだよと
子に個性があることを知った上で
平等心を
育てます
これは
仏教が言う
道徳の意図するなんです
平等の気持ち
育ちなさいよと
これは本来あなた方にないんだよと
自己中心だから
無名によってきているんだから
この次元の
変える
より良いより良い高い次元に
心を向上させてあげれば
平等心を
育ちなさいと
仏教は平等に育ち
言ったからでいて
世の中平等じゃないんですありえない
魚に足がないのはその生命の
個性です
しかし魚を差別するならばそれそれが
間違いの行為です
我々これって
理解してくださいこのなんかバカな例え
じゃないんです
魚に足がないんです
足持っている私がいいこいつのアシストか
ねなんでかわいそうな奴だとか思った自分
が
酷いだけでしょう
自分に心が汚れたんだから
それは悪行為ですそういうことで我々
至って簡単にはここにするんです
だからあの
レカレーションの魚たちに立っても私は
この魚が好きこの
魚がでもこの
魚が気持ち悪いとかね
やっているでしょう
結構悪法で心が汚れます
悪いません
はいこんなもんで終わるまたありますね
人の心に
生命は平等だという
理解が
現れることは人格向上です
それだけで人格向上です
その人に
理性があるんです
生命は平等であるとこれ
修行ですよ
その気持ちになったらその人に理性がある
んです
その人は
善の道歩んでいます
平等心はレベルの高い修行になります
これ
シャッターじゃないんです
世にある
世間で料理
心を
実行しているか否かを
探すのではなく
自分自身が
自分の心にこの理解と能力を
育ててみるんです
みんな
世間で平等じゃないとかねあの偉大なる
アメリカでも黒人サービスあるんだよとか
ねそんなことはどうでもいいんで自分の心
に
平等心があるかないかをチェックするしか
ないんです
貪瞋痴の悪感情を
戒めないとこの修行はできませんまぁ一緒
でしょう
平等心育てると
貪瞋痴がずっと
機能しなくなる
心はと心情が
ずっと高次元に上がった上がっていくん
です
仏教では梵天次元まで上がるんだよという
意味です
だからこの自費者の瞑想で
GT社4つも
生命平等という立場行きとし生きるものが
というフレッシュ飼っているでしょう
殺人去った
だからたったその単語だけどれほど行動の
教えかとこれ
内容から理解してください
仏教はまあのことを笑うんじゃなくて
どれほど行動かと
私はYouTubeでもねあの
エキサーテルス
生命体が来てね
突然こちら文化を作っちゃって
突然
遺伝子組み合わせで人間作っちゃって
[音楽]
何となく自分と似ているでも作った
ばっかしい能力ないんだから
開発したらまた
戻りマット出て行ったとかね
それで人間がドカーンとうちちゃってもう
どんどんコソコソコソコソ
文化を返せていくんだという話ですよ
仏教の話では
これも飛んでいるんです
それも飛んでいるんです
生命はこういうものやと
梵天神が回っても
業によってこういう風に
心の次元があげることはできますけどそれ
も教えて
全部やめて
無執着に
達してくださいというところまで
仏教教えているんですはい
そこで終わるでしょうと
はい
すごい長い時間喋りましたけどね2
番目のセクション
休憩しますはいそれでは10分ほど休憩
いたしますので
3時50分頃に大会したいと思いますので
それまで
休憩といたしますよろしくお願いいたし
ます
あのねどう楽しみながら
すごい
楽しいという感じで聞けばこの深い
心理理解できますよ
なんかちょっとそういう風に
置くか
みんな腹が立ちますからしょうがない
でしょう
だからこういうのは
人間に理解できないくらい
難しいものだからちょっとなんか
気分良く楽しく
明るくニコニコ笑って
聞かないと
理解できないんです
ではこの
平等心って言っただけであーまぁ聞き慣れ
ているつまらない話やと思ったでしょうで
も本当のところ違うでしょう
これも同じです
公平
私の副題は期待するが
実現
実現は
難しい
はいさっさと行きますこれかなり
膨大です
このポイントは
簡単ではないこれ
3人での
本書いちゃったんです
サッカーです
で
数学やら数字やらやこれが出てくるんだ
からもう私のめんどくさくて
本があります
裁判などの人の
判断が欠かせない
仕事に置いては
決して
公平な
判断は
得られないという
問題を研究されています
でこのテキストでいろんな幅広く扱って
ますけど
我々はいろんな判断しなきゃいけない大
会社になってくると
CEやらねこういう管理
毎年ごとに
雇うでしょう
その時エントリーボールで
このインテビボールは会社やらないんです
それのプロがいるんです
プロたちが来て人々をするんですよで
判断するんでしょう
でもああいう判断はコーヒーにならないん
だといくら何でも一応
面白かった
データたくさんなってね
この
裁判
官たちが
判決出す場合はね
アメリカの
[音楽]
入国
アメリカに
住民として認める人生
認定欲しくてみんな裁判にかけるんですね
弁護士として
そこで
データを見て
アメリカの
住民にする
資格あるならばOKなかったら罰だけ
でしょう
それで
ある
裁判はこの
100人
調べると
50人もOKならないとある
裁判は100人調べると
780年ぐらい大きな
それでいっぱいデータがあったんだからね
そこで
私の後ろ勝ったら
あるいくらか優しい
気持ち持っている裁判官がいて
午前中の
審判で
これはい
次これどんどん昼になってくるでしょう
だから早くもOKするためにも話聞いか
なくちゃあかんだからねもう
昼ご飯食べたいねこいつは
だから残った
ファイルは全部
却下
これコーヒーじゃないでしょう
そこでこの本書いている人がこの
デジタルという言葉はっきり使っています
私たちは判決を求めて裁判に行っても
OKになるかバスになるかということで
露天だよ
9時だよと
でも法律はしっかりしているどんなどんな
条件で
入国見てみるか認めないかもある
そういう子に人の
判断をコーヒーにならない
状況はこのテキストでノイズという言葉で
使っていますよ
ノイズたくさんあるシステムのあれこれや
とかね
システムのはそのその組織で
決まっている色々
変な
どうにもならん決まりとかね
こういうのは残念ながら
ヒューマンですこれは日本語訳ちょっと
できない
血管ですね
入学で言えば
人間本来持っている結果なんです
公平に
判断できないこと
専門家まここから私の話になります
専門家だけではなく一般社会もでも
判断を行う場合は
公費になりません
家庭の中でもいろんなことを判断する
でしょう
コーヒーやと思う
全く公平じゃないんです
お母さんだから公平に判断するととんでも
ないんです
お父さんだから公園に判断するとかありえ
ないんですね
だって夫婦の間でもね
意見変わっちゃうでしょう
でこの
公平っていう私は
英語で調べてこの日本語の言葉をねまず
英語の単語を頭に入れてその単語で意味
するものは分析していくんですだから日本
で
同じ意味ですからね
いわゆる
誰かの方持たないっていう意味でしょうね
我々は期待しましょう
学校の教師が
強兵であるコーヒーでやってほしいとかね
母親だから公平でやってほしいとかね
期待はあるんだけどこれはありえないん
ですよ中で
だから不公平やって訴えて意味がないん
です
不公平やと言っている人も公平じゃないん
はい
バランスが崩れるでこれからまあ私の話
テキストは皆さん参考にしただけで
人は
判断しなきゃならない
例えばさくらんぼの皿がある
子供3人が
3人にちゃんと稼いで
分けるとしましょう
これも判断です
そうするとさくらんぼ一個一個取ってみる
と
筋質均等にないんですね
ちょっと大きいものもあってちょっと
小さいものもあって
はい一人に
ごっこずつやと
でも
ごっこもらったらあること
なんかこれがちっちゃい
[笑い]
妹の方が全部大きい
なっちゃうんですね
それで母親から見てもそうなんですけど
どうすればいいんですかね
それでまた2個
残っているでしょう
これも頂戴頂戴3人見たらどうしますか
困りますよ
うるさいんだから誰かに
二人にあげるでしょう
不公平な判断でしょうそれであの三人が
喧嘩するんです
こういうことで
かなり大変ですしかし
毎日判断しなくちゃあんです
すべて判断難しいのは
全ての情報が
一人が得られないんです
書き忘れたんだけど
全て情報を得ようとしちゃうと
イラン情報まで入っちゃうんです
まぁ例えば日本ではないんだけどアメリカ
の
トップグレードの大学なんかに入る場合は
まぁこれ
全部もう
調べて
判断するんです
大体
アプリケーションに受けたんだから一応
資格はみんなにあるんですが
何人か
カットしなくちゃかんです
それでいろいろ情報を調べるんです
その中では書いたけど避けてちょっと
交通違反で
50か20ドル罰金
払うことになったとそれだけであこれは
本当になるでしょう
もしかすると
でもその人すごい学力能力ある
本物になる可能性もあるしノベル賞を取る
可能性があるんです
だからその
判断する場合はその学生さんたちの
全部
学問的な能力とエクサー
はチェックするんですそれから精神状態
サイコロ軸にしてそういういくつかの項目
に分けて
調べては行くんです
でもそれって
ぴったり全てデータくるわけじゃないん
です
そこでこの人が
自分に与えたファイル
例えば20ありますから
これでこの子供の
学生の
電話番号調べて
母親父親どこにいるのか結婚
離婚しているのか分かれているのかまだ
一緒かとかね
電話だ父親からあなたの息子はどんなもの
かそこまで聞いちゃうと
要らんことまで聞いちゃうんですね
どうせ両親が
かなり
大げさに
言うでしょう
あるいは逆に
気に入らないもう
離婚して別れていて
奥さんのこと未だに怒っているだったら
娘息子の御料ではもう勝手にやって
くださいという感じで
だから大変でしょう
情報を得られないだけじゃなくて
情報を得ようとすると
アウトポイント情報まで入っちゃうんです
ね
関係外の
情報まで入っちゃうんです
これでよってもこんがらがっちゃって
判断できなくなるんですねそれから
情報処理する能力
人は様々です
人は自分の都合に合わせて情報を提供する
だから
情報提供してくださいと
言ったら
自分の救いに合わせて
業務提供するのです
若い者にあんたの
場合を
出してください言った途端一番最初に私は
回
挑戦サービスにの判決を受けたことがある
と書いちゃうと
それから何がいたって
本当になっちゃうんです
要するに
若者だから
罰金も刑務所もなくなんかどこかで言って
調査整備しなさいと
これ3回目それなんですもらってそれから
学校で優勝
トップグレードに
ハイスクールではもう
抜群なもう
で
成功がやったとかね
スポーツもサッカーやりましたとかね
大砲であれは全部あの最初のあれで
消されてしまうのですねそれ正しくない
でしょうそれ
で怒るんです
エスポーツ能力は抜群にあっても
ある日高充分殴ったとしたならば
それだけで守ることになる
可能性ありますよ
そこでぶん殴ったことはどういうことか
どんな関係でそれ避けることできたんです
かこの人精神的に不安でしたかとこれは
高知の性格こちらの生活ここまで調べられ
ませんでしょう
体調によっても判断左右されますよ
じゃあ私もね
喋る場合はね
体調によって
力
加減
変えます
人には
好みとその反対もありますねどんな人にも
ありますよ
じゃったら
どうしようもない年齢性別なども影響を
与える
判断する側の年齢性です
判断される側の年齢性別によっても
例えば裁判官だったら
異国人が女性の場合は
緩やかな判断がするでしょう
被告人が見たら筋肉ブリブリのごっつい
とこだったらじゃあ3年
金庫
ってなるんです
それで
裁判官が男か女かに言っても
変わるんです
七面倒くさいの私は法律
良くしてください読んでみたところで
こういうことを犯したら
1年から5年以内の
インプションになるとあれは
罰金の場合は1万から20万
あっているんですね
だから
裁判官の場合は一応有罪になっちゃったん
だけど
罰金
1万にする10万人にする
ちょっと美味しく刑務所に入れた方がいい
やとじゃあ一瞬一週間にする1ヶ月間に
する1ヶ月1年にするとか
ね
はい逆に
法律を作る場合はこの間違いを起こしたら
犯したら3年やと
明確に書くことも不可能です
というわけで
これ
期待できないこの世の中で
コーヒーな判断ははい次に行きます
数人の判断
これで人々は
いいことをするんですよとはパネル
アメリカでありますね
で会議などを行って
議論して
データを調べて
判断するようにします
すると一人じゃないでしょう
あの裁判でも
何人か
裁判官が
特にあの
殺人罪の場合とかね
公平な判断したいでしょう
ダメですそれでも
しかし家庭と判断後たくさんまとめても
新しい合成したかという
判断が
現れるだけです
意味がないんですこれ頑張ってますよ
裁判所で3人がいたり
七人がいたり
消して4人がいないんです
大変なことになるんです
わかるでしょう意味は
5人
ありが3人あるいは七人
それだけでもわかるでしょう
曖昧やと
判断
別れてもあれ2で割れませんだからね
どちらか一票高いんですね
そちらにするんです
面白いことは
現実はそうなんですけど
みんな歌ってますね
公正な判断
基づいてとかねこの野郎
面白いことから
民主とそれから
判断
偏る
原理
民主的な考え
民主
でしょうかね
これ
民主党変えて
人種
的な考え
主これ習慣
習慣
文化
伝統
宗教
信仰
自分の年齢
性別人の知識それから時間
そういうもの栄光は
影響を与えて
判断に多大な影響を与えるんです
まぁ一番分かりやすい例はね
例えば
イスラム教の人が
苦手を首を切って
ちゃんと首を切って
これこそ
コーラに則った
清らかな食べ物食べちゃう私に入れたら
ニワトリの首を
切ることはどうでしょうかと私は仏教と
いう偏見でしょうこれは接触だからダメや
あの人
いますこの
甲羅の
決まっているフレーズがあってそれで一発
で首を切って
血液を全部
捨てればOKと
になるんだよと
どうしますかね
[拍手]
宗教によってもねまぁそういう風に影響を
与えます
経験が
豊かであることを思う
経験が少ないことも
判断に影響を与える
大体考えればすごい経験豊かな人を判断
する場合は
しっかり判断するんじゃない
経験豊かだからこそあまり調べないで
これはもう
こういうことがする可能性もあります
使う言語によっても
物事によく価値見方が
変わります
例えば言語によっても例えば
納得して単語する方でしょう
英語で言っちゃうとなんかえらいかっこ
いい単語なんですそれは日本語訳すると
日本が分からんだけどどうなるかわからん
ね
だからでしょう日本語でも
結構カタカナ単語あるでしょうに
例えば証拠にはエビデンスと英語の単語
でしょうこれカタカナで日本語でも同じ
単語使っちゃうんですね
その時の差別があるんですよ
記憶あるのあんたエビデンス持っている
エイリアンスは何ですかと
態度でかいね
同じ日本語英語喋る人間じゃないんです
だから
言語も影響を与えるでしょうなんだね
はい
次に行きます
それにポイントから多数派の意見どうです
かとこれ民主主義世界でね
グループの
多数派の見解も
公平で
正しいわけではありませんよ
仕方がなくやっているんだけど
反対するグループもいるんだからその人々
のそれなりに理由があるんだから
問題は
反対する
反対意見
判決出す人々の
判断も
汚れていますね
賛成という人々の判断もいます
だから
多数の意見だから
公平で正しいわけでもないしだったら
少数に行けそれも
公平で正しいわけじゃないんです
民主主義に従って公平な判断を
得られる保証はありません
皆さんは民主主義国家に住んでいる
でしょうバンバン
歳に
公平でありえないでしょう
面白く考えたのはコロナ初めて時は
政府はみんなに10万円小型でしょう私は
もらったんですあれは公平な判断ででも私
はそれは高齢かなとかね思ったんです
あれ面倒くさいんだからそうしたんです
なぜか出てから十分どうでもいいやと思う
ハチャメチャ
金持ちいるでしょうに
そこで
私も
面白くないどんなのはめんどくさいとかね
思ってて
手紙来たら
受け取るか受け取らないかという
選択あったんですねどうしてくれるんだっ
たら受け取る
書いたらなんか
銀行口座に入ったみたいだけどそれは
ガチャガチャだって25万
誰かにあげるんですだから15万損しまし
た
でその
例はいいでしょうにねだから政府が
みんなにあげる
あれって怠け判断でしょう
結局はこれ政府は経済援助することだから
より
困っている人にもうちょっとたくさん投げ
て
全くイラン人にはあげないで
まあまあな人にはまぁ10万にするとかね
こんなことできないでしょう政府にとって
は
それにも膨大に金がかかるでしょう
調べて調べて調べて
書く
役所で
役所で人がたくさん並んでいてとかね
今はネットでもできますけどね
ではネットを使わない年寄り見ますからね
ああ面倒くさいはい
みんな順番ね
だから
公平のように見えてもそれ
すらちょっと偏った
判断判断なんです
今日は何曜日
今は何時
などの問いには正しい答えを
得られますが
今日の気分はいかがでしょうかと
言うとどう答えればいいんですかね
信頼できる客観性のある答え
返事
得られません
私に聞いたら今日の気分はどうですかと
言ったら
私もわかりませんは相手の顔を見て返事
するんだから
科学的に客観的に
自分の気持ちを判断して言わないんです
じゃあもっと簡単なリアリあります今何時
という
あなた今何時だと思う
その場合時計見ないでしょう今何時だと
思うどうですか答えは
何時だと思うと果てに入れちゃうと判断
でしょう
バラバラになりますね
この食べ物は美味しいか
田舎を判断する場合は
変化になります
でもこちらどれくらいキャリアやりますか
とかね
内容聞いたら
客観的なデータで
言えます
人の話を使ってないんですその場合は
わかりますかね我々はまるっきり後にない
当てにならない
判断の世界で生きているんです
はい次に行きます
そこで私はこのゆなりまして何ですかね
日本語日本語で
みんな同じ意見というね
全会一致
新開地
お釈迦様が
人間の
判断に
ノイズが入っていると昔から知っていたん
です
ですから
三田という小さなグループ作って
そちらの運営についての判断は
旋回一致
千人一致でなければ
無効
例えば
201人の出家がいて20人もまぁこうし
ましょう一人が
私がこれ違うと思いますとアウト
実行できないんです
なぜかというとこの
判断は信頼できない
選民一致だったらまぁしょうがないんです
例え間違った判断であっても
しっかりそこでお釈迦様精密に気をつけて
いるんです
真理に対して
勝手に判断してはいけないんだと
ブッダリと身体としそこでブッダリとか
あると教えばこれこれあると
決まっておいたんですだから
参考すればいいんです
そうするとあってますと自分で
判断するそれは自分の主観的に判断じゃ
ないんです
何のにお坊さんてこれも
ハチャメチャにしちゃったんです
ブッダの教えはこうではなく派ではない
こうではないあれやこれやといろんな様な
アイディアが出てきて
宗派まで別れてしまったんですね
意見が
別れた場合は
専門家のコミュニティ
で情報を調べるんでこれお釈迦様の推薦し
ています
あるお坊さんの間で大体戒律ですけど
問題が起きたお坊さんたちのこれよう
わからん
この人
言うことも
正しいに見えるし
反対する人の意見を正しく見える
わからんだったらお釈迦様があなた方では
なくて
別に
プロの専門家の
神で作ってくださいと
そのコミュニティにこの問題を出して
小道はどんな意見持ってないんだからその
判断を取ってくださいと
いうことでこの
判断は
公平な判断不可能ということでお釈迦様も
悩んでいたんです
どう管理するのかと
しかし
ブッダが気をつけていろんな
条件付けたんだけど
ブッダの
公平判断技も
狭い範囲でしか
実行できません
論理的には
誰がどんな時でも
同じ結論に達することが
事実で
正しい判断になりますが
でしょう
どんな時でも
同じ結論に達する
朝晩でも一連がどうでも
そうすると正しい判断です
全ての条件に
合格しているのは
ブッダが解いた
真理の教えだけです
仕方がないんです
ブッダが解かれた真理だけは
どんな時間でも通じましょうと
どんな生命にも当てはめますよ
と自分で調べて判断してくださいと
まぁブッダの真理と
簡単で言えば
全ての現象は無常である
変わる
変わらないそれは
朝は無常じゃないんだけどここは無常とか
ありえないんです
生きることは苦であるということはこれは
もう
どんな生命にまた会えます
それでそういうわけで
ブッダが教えた戒律ではないんです
真理
しかしブッダが教えた戒律の
基礎
は
真理です
それは心理学だからね
それ以外この世の中で何もないんです
正しい判断で
決めたものというの
公平なんだねはい次に行きます
そこで怪しいなと
よくありますね
他人の判断が
公平で良かったと喜ぶことは
度々やりますね
私はテレビ画面
頭に
映る裁判でねみんなこの
縦に書いた
色々
看板看板じゃなくて
ねえそうそう
持っていて
喜んじゃうんですね
関係して出ましたとかね
あの人は有罪になったとかね
見るたびに私は
笑っちゃいます
これは
本当に怪しいんです
本人が自分の
主観的な感情に
適合する判断を得ただけです
自分の子供か旦那が殺されちゃって
この犯人を裁判で調べている
そこで
被害を受けた人々は
有罪だと
死刑
裁判官が決めた途端
走って外を入れてあのかけ軸をかけて
じゃあ
喜んじゃったり
テレビに
インタビューに喋ったりとかね
その場合は
公平な判断にいたんじゃなくて
自分の
主観で決めた
変形な判断が
出ただけです
例えば仏教的に見ると
殺人が多かったかもしれませんその人更新
することですかね
それもあり得るでしょう
客観的な
客観的なデータに基づくならば
客観的な判断
得られます
客観的なデータあるならば自分に関係ない
だったら
客観的な
判断は
得られます
こちら10万円の束があるこちら100万
人の束があるどちらが多い
簡単でしょうそこで曖昧なでしょう
5CMなら10万の方が追いついたり午後
は
悪魔の方が置いていったりありえない
でしょう
しかしそれならアルゴリズムを書いて
機械に判断任せても
同じ議会ですそれだから逃げ切れない
今全部
システム管理だからアルコール展も書いて
こういう
情報だよとこの子の情報でこのこの判断
代表で言ったら
機械はちょっと判断出してくれます
人間がメーターが好きでしょう
人間が複数のメーターを開発します
何でもメーターできるでしょう
熱を測る
血圧を
測る
欠席の糖度を
図る
全てメーターですね
車にスピードはメーターが判断します
運転手は判断しませんよ
運転しか判断したら大変なことになる
これぐらいちょろ大丈夫大丈夫という
気持ちでしょうでもスピードメーター見る
と
12080と書いてますからね
頑張って
一人負けたらそれ大変です最終的に行き
ます
では仏教の答えで終了します
判断をできるだけ
避けることしかありません
できれば
判断
できるだけ
避けて
生きる
例えばあの
さくらんぼを配る場合は
一応
山道に
作って
123と書いて
口を引いてみる
それから向くような音あんた2だからに
利尿皿取ってくださいと
これはあの出家世界で使う一つの習慣なん
です
色んな品物お布施見ちゃうともうバラバラ
お坊さんたち
一人に一個一個にはならないその場合は
適当に誰か認定したお坊さんが
品物を
例えば10人いるんだったら
12分けるんです
中身は同じじゃないんです
で取れば個人の判断で適当にねだから高い
ものもあるし安いものもあったりとかね
それから一から10まででしょう
それで
口を
書いて一人一人
撮ってくださいと
だから
旧取った人をもらった品物はあまり価値が
ないものと言ってもまぁしょうがないそれ
の場合はだからこれはあなたのこうやと
いうしかない
それから
ギリギリまで
データに持つついて判断します出家は
経典と一層のデータを参考します
アラカンも
判断後間違ったエピソードもありますよ
何の煩悩も感情もないですが
たまにあるか判断間違うと
判断をしてもうそれに
執着してしがみつかないことにします
判断はプロがあるんだよと
血管があるんだよと嫉妬を置いた方が
執着はないんです
全ては無常だから
判断も無常であることを知ります
裁判などでは自分の過ちを自分で見てみる
ことを
厳しく欲求します
仏教の場合は一緒に仏教でもいろいろ問題
起こしちゃってお
坊さんたちの裁判に連れてきますよ
でも裁判みたいな大げさなことじゃねぇ
この人はこういうことやりましたよと
訴えるんです
訴えたら仏教の決まりは本音に聞くんです
あなたこれ
認めますか認めないか
だから出家だから
自分がやったならば
認めることが乖離そうです
認めないやってないと嘘言っちゃうと
あなたのゲラスに大きな
壁が現れるんだよという
脅しがあるんですそういうのは本物の私
です
ですからそこで人間だから
間違いおかしますよ
犯したら誰かお坊さんが訴えちゃうんです
よ
ほんとこういうこと言ってますけどやった
のはいすいませんやりましたじゃあ
懺悔してください
終わり
はい
公平を壊す感情
さ
れます
生きる上で避けなくてはいけない
感情4つありますこれはお釈迦様がこの
単語は入れ忘れちゃったんだけど
判断は
偏る原因とはっきり書いてみる上がって
いわゆる公平を
壊す
原理
お釈迦様子だけ教えたんでこれ4つ教えた
のはこれ一番重大であるし何とか管理
できるんです
1ちゃうんだよこの
みんなにあるでしょう
使うなよと判断するときは
にどうせ気分が悪い腹が立っているまぁ
そういうことは昔から私は嫌いやとかね
それは使わない
3番目バイそれは
if
恐怖どちらでも
宗教的な感じるあれもダメなんです
4番目はもう
ようわからんだからまぁもうこれあんた
勇者と
か
判断する時は
債権も出家もこの4つの感情を
避けるので叫んなさいとお釈迦様
おっしゃっているこれは出家最低両方に
教えているんですなぜならば判断は誰だっ
てやらなくちゃあんです
ちゃんとどうす場合もあるというこれは
シガーラ経典にもありますはい
て終わりましたやっと
ということでかなりあの
公平と軽々と言ったってもこれはすごい
深い心理があって人間なら不完全な
組み立てだから
公平な判断は
期待できませんだから手で人ばかりの人は
いけませんできるだけまぁ
判断は
ベターな判断にするしかないんです
平等の場合は
超越した次元の
知恵があってこれは修行であって
現実科学的な事実として
平等っていうのはないんです
はい以上ですどうもありがとうございます
[拍手]
はい
ちょうどちょっと時間の過ぎておりますの
でこれで
終了したいと思います
では最後に
高橋洋子さんの
お布施でこの方は
1回できましたことで
はなくなった
お父様にの
ご冥福を祈ります
路線式の亡くなったすべての方々にも
幸福でありますようにと
先に
脱出することができますように
正解に対しますそれから
生きとし生きるもの
全ての生命にも
移行するという感じてますからね
全ての生命がこのどこによって皆様も孤独
を吸いましたからね
説法を切ることも孤独ですからね
によって全ての生命も幸福でありますよう
にと
誓願しましょうさあ動作はい
終了します
合掌して
みんなで合唱してください
[音楽]
ドッカーチェーンパズパーチェに
するか
本当
三平の
苦しんで悩む生命が
苦しみなく
恐れて悩む生命が
恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しむなく一歳の生命
があるのでありますように
はいどうもありがとうございます
長澤先生ありがとうございましたそれでは
少し時間が超過してしまいましたが
本日の
初期仏教実例講演会協議をいたします
皆様もスマートフォンその他のお手回りの
ものをお忘れ物ないようにお気をつけてお
帰りください
次回の初期仏教を月例講演会2022年の
最後の講演会となりますが12月18日の
日曜日の1時半から4時半の予定で
東京都
千代田区の一橋にあります一橋構造という
ところで
開催されますタイトルは
ダマシー騙される人生
騙されたくないからこそ騙されるという
タイトルでお送りいたします
ホームページとでまた
申し込みホームが
上がっていると思いますのでそちらの方
からお申し込みの上また
いつもよりかなり大きな会場になりますの
で
ぜひお誘い合わせの上でお越しいただけれ
ばと思いますそれでは本日はどうも
ありがとうございましたお気をつけ動画
下さい